the Dominican Republic's defense
minister visiting the border for the
first time since his country ordered it
closed to neighboring
hati that decision was made to pressure
Haitian Farmers to stop digging a canal
on the masaku river which the two
countries
share we took the opportunity to ask him
about the fairness of the Dominican
Republic's
demands
but none of those projects diverts the
course of the river this one does and
that's why it violates the treaty but
the Haitians say they're suffering from
drought and have a right to irrigate
their farmlands they continue to dig
despite the buildup of Dominican troops
on the other side of the border the
Dominican government wants to show off
what it's doing but at the moment that's
really all this is a show they can't
actually do anything to stop the canal
which is on the Haitian side
neither it seems can the Haitian
government even if it wanted to years of
political crisis and violence have left
it all but
incapacitated even most of the capital
portal Prince is in the hands of gangs
so how I asked the Dominican defense
minister does it expect that same
Haitian government to resolve the
crisis we know that the Haiti government
because of the actions of the gangs has
its hands tied but the construction of
the canal affects the interest of the
Dominican Republic it affects our
farmers and it violates the Treaty of
1929 so it's up to the government to
search for a solution it's in their
hands meanwhile the closed border is
affecting not just Haans who depend on
food from the wealthier Dominican
Republic but also Traders and exporters
on this side the Dominican industry and
commerce Minister also at the border to
reassure Traders promised to buy off any
perishable food they can't sell I asked
him how long his government could do
that for
the limit of time doesn't depend on us
it depends on hati now we hope that the
talks advance and we continue to
reposition our products
internally meanwhile in Haiti support
for the canal is only growing perhaps
because of Dominican opposition it's
becoming a patriotic Endeavor flags are
fluttering busloads of people are
arriving to help some performing voodoo
rituals in support of the workers others
like zapi magdal are bringing
food we've come to support the canal
being built because we are Haitians we
must cooperate among ourselves to give
food to those who work at the
canal the Dominican Republic insists
that Haitian businessmen and politicians
are behind the project but however it's
started the canal has become very much a
popular Enterprise orbe it one that
could cause economic ruin if the two
countries continue their standoff John
Homan Al jazer the habon
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al
jazer